le film évènement de ce festival c'est
la reine margot alias isabelle adjani
film réalisé par patrice chéreau et
présenté demain à cannes le même jour
vendredi 13 les producteurs ans ne sont
pas superstitieux apparemment ce film
sortira dans 250 salles en france
un budget d'environ 120 millions de
francs pour 2h39 d'histoire de france
revue et corrigée par alexandre dumas
patrice chéreau et danièle thompson sans
sexe religion politique passion et
ambition tout y est dans ce drame
élisabéthain qui se transforme en
règlement de comptes entre clans mafieux
véritable western de la renaissance
un film dont la fiche est
particulièrement riche reportage pascal
deschamps magnifique elle après
cinquante préparation six mois de
tournage autant dire cinq ans et demi de
bruit et de rumeurs la reine margot le
film arrive au grand galop et pas
n'importe où au festival de cannes donc
on l'a dit et répété c'est l'un des
événements les plus attendus
c'est dans ce climat qu'ont débarqué cet
après-midi les comédiens du film
salut royaux de circonstance pour la
reine-mère et pour son fils isabelle
adjani est là mais elle se cache se
réservant sans doute pour la
traditionnelle montée des marches
alors c'est sa bande qui monte au
créneau et quelle bande moi c'est
catherine de médicis cayla maire de
margaux vous présente big anglade fait
charles neuf le roi de france en crise
son fils julien fait le duc d'alençon le
fils de catherine aussi qui ne sera
jamais roi et pascal greggory fait le
duc d'anjou qui deviendra roi henri iii
à la fin du film
une bande dont les membres sont rarement
mort dans leur lit ou alors empoisonné
une bande qui quand elle ne s'entretuent
pas pour régner tu les autres comme
cette sinistre nuit de la saint
barthélémy où charlot 9 ordonna le
massacre des protestants à rita
cimetière qu'est ce qui se passe
maintenant yougoslavie en bosnie je veux
dire on tue par dizaines par grappes
entières ou honda ou ailleurs aussi à
l'aise je crois que ces processus de
folie d'hystérie qui fait que osseux tu
es finances a dit un acte anodin
moi ce qui m'intéressait c'est cette
sauvagerie c7 c'est cette capacité
d'être finalement incroyablement
actuelle incroyablement comme comme peut
l'être une un texte de shakespeare ou de
houe de marleau c'est finalement une
sorte de barbarie très primitive est
très très proche de nous enchanter
metteur en scène de théâtre ou d'opéra
patrice chéreau a réalisé une oeuvre
très forte sur laquelle convergent
peut-être trop de regard à son goût il
faut faire très attention aux films
qu'on attend trop et moi j'attends pas
grand chose du festival de cannes
j'espère que ça se passe simplement et
que les gens auront envie de le voir en
du plaisir à le voir ce qui lui fait
sans doute encore plus peur c'est que le
film sort demain dans toute la france à
14h05 heure avant la projection cannoise